good afternoon everyone i'm here to
provide an update on covet 19 in the
province of alberta with the chief
medical officer of health dr dina
hinshaw
for the last five weeks since we began
step one and in the two weeks since we
entered step two we've been able to
enjoy life in a different way than we
have had over the past two years
with the majority of restrictions lifted
we've gathered with loved ones
visited restaurants played sports and
made our own decisions about masking
outside of settings like health care
facilities where they're still required
i know this shift has been easier for
some
than others and i know that many have
cautiously been watching to see what
impact if any these changes may have had
so i'm pleased to report that it does
not appear that easy measures has caused
an uptick in numbers since we entered
step one on february the eighth
we continue to see a decline or plateau
in both our lagging and leading
indicators
there's been some variation in the
positivity rate for pcr tests
but overall since step 1 began it has
dropped by 7
there's also been a continuing steady
decline in the most important lagging
indicator hospitalizations
today hospitalizations are down to 989
including 70 in icu both those figures
are down by around 40 percent from when
we began easing measures
it will take time for hospitalizations
to get down to the level before the
fifth wave
but this is promising news for the
health system our health care workers
have given their all to care for
albertans through the ups and downs of
the pandemic they need relief and
they're beginning to get it
alberta is going through a period of
transition
as we shift out of crisis mode and move
toward an endemic response we can make
adjustments to the way we operate
which is why i would like to announce
two changes that we are making to our
covet 19 response
first we are modifying our public data
reporting
beginning next week we'll join other
provinces such as saskatchewan and
reducing case and outbreak reporting to
once per week
data for the previous seven days will be
available each wednesday
with this shift we'll also consolidate
some of the data posted to alberta.ca to
reflect the most relevant current
information
for example as contact tracing currently
is being done only in high-risk settings
we're removing the source of exposure
graph that lists most cases as being
from an unknown source
i know this will be adjustment for some
albertans who have become used to
checking the website on a daily basis
throughout the pandemic alberta has been
a leader in reporting
providing more comprehensive data than
other provinces and territories
we have been and remain committed to
ensuring albertans have the information
they need
but we've also adjusted as we went
early on we provided numbers seven days
a week and held media availabilities
like this five times a week
that was critical when little was known
about the virus
but we're at a point where trends over
longer periods of time are more relevant
than day-to-day fluctuations
i want to be clear that alberta health
including dr henshaw and her team will
continue to closely monitor the data
here as well as emerging evidence from
other jurisdictions
and they'll bring forward any policy
recommendations if and when needed in
the future
another change we're making is to our
employer and service provider rapid
testing program
throughout the pandemic alberta has had
a robust rapid testing program
we started with the employer and service
program to help reduce transmission in
higher risk workplaces
we've ensured rapid tests are available
in critical environments including
continuing care sites homeless shelters
and in schools
and since december we've expanded the
at-home rapid test program to provide
access to rapid tests for all albertans
as of last friday we distributed
over 34.2 million tests including 13.2
million directly to albertans
our government has worked hard to ensure
that there is ample supply
now that rapid tests kits are broadly
available to all albertans and employers
scaled down mandatory testing programs
we're winding down the employer and
service provider program as planned
this program has been focused on regular
asymptomatic testing at work sites which
is no longer required in the majority of
settings
as of april 1st the program will only be
available to employers and service
providers who care for vulnerable
populations
this includes ahs locations as well as
long-term care designated supported
living and hospice facilities primary
care
child care k-12 school staff
and community services that look after
vulnerable populations including
shelters and residential addiction
treatment facilities
that being said i want to remind all
albertans that free rapid test kits
continue to be available at pharmacies
across the province
a list of locations with kits in stock
is available on the alberta blue cross
website
to make the process even easier
healthcare number is no longer required
finally
as our initial pediatric vaccine drive
concludes today i want to let parents
and guardians of children know that
we're adjusting the hours of walk-in
pediatric vaccine clinics run by ahs
until march 31st ahs clinics will
continue to offer flexible hours
including some evening availability to
maximize opportunities for eligible
children to be immunized
availability will vary throughout the
province to find an ahs clinic with
extended hours and walk-in appointments
please visit
ahs.ca backslash vaccine
a reminder parents and guardians can
also book appointments online for
children age 5 and older through the
alberta vaccine booking system or by
calling eight one one
additionally children to vaccination
vaccines are still available at a number
of pharmacies across the province so for
more details please go to the blue cross
website
i want to thank every young albertan who
has rolled up their sleeve to get the
covid vaccine you've helped protect
yourself and those around you from
getting seriously ill from covet 19 and
also help to protect our health care
system even though many things are
changing i want to
remind albertans that we know how to
best protect one another
vaccines offer our best protection
against severe illness for each of us
and for all of us together
as well each of us is free to judge what
safety measures make sense for our own
personal situation and we need to
respect those choices
covid is not over but it's time to move
forward
we're learning to live with it and each
of us will do that in our own way
and we all still need to follow the
measures that remain in place including
masking in high risk settings and
isolation for people who have symptoms
and have tested positive
thank you and i'll now invite dr hinshaw
to the podium
to say a few words
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
i want to begin today by speaking about
the process our team goes through to
ensure that the numbers we report to
albertans are accurate
this process is particularly important
when it comes to severe outcomes such as
the number of lives lost to covid19
in our regular reports deaths where
covet has been flagged as a possible
cause are included even if it is not yet
confirmed at that time
then health staff review the death
certificate and files of any cases where
the cause of death was unknown at the
time of reporting to determine whether
the virus was a contributing cause
if it is found that kovid was not a
primary or contributing cause of death
we remove those deaths from the count of
lives lost to the virus
our most recent review has found that
there are 16 previously reported deaths
between december 21st and february 11
that did not have covet 19 as a
contributing cause
38 other deaths reported in this time
frame were also reviewed and in those
cases it was confirmed that kovid was a
direct or contributing cause of death
this means that with the four new deaths
that we have had reported to us in the
last 24 hours the total number of deaths
in alberta related to covid19 will be
updated today to
4013 deaths
a net decrease of 12.
while getting the data correct is very
important we cannot lose sight that each
of these numbers no matter the cause of
death represent a life lost and the
loved ones left behind to grieve them
my sympathies go out to all those who
have experienced a loss no matter the
cause
i also want to pause on this total to
reflect on the impact of covid compared
with other kinds of infections
in the three years before covet from
2017 to 2019
there were a total of
1076 deaths from all infectious causes
in all ages
covet has taken almost four times more
lives in just two years
thankfully vaccines have blunted the
risk of severe outcomes giving us the
opportunity to change how we are
managing this virus
at the same time
covet is still a disease we must take
seriously
moving on to today's update over the
last 24 hours we have identified 593 new
cases of covet 19 and completed about
3200 pcr tests which puts our positivity
rate at 18
as the minister mentioned there are
currently 989 people with covid19 in
hospital including 70 in the icu
from the beginning of the pandemic i
have been committed to ensuring
albertans have had access to timely and
accurate information about covid19
that priority remains today two years
later and as we find ourselves in a very
different situation than when covid
first arrived in alberta
that is why i believe that modifying our
public reporting to once a week as the
minister just announced is the right
thing to do
we will continue to post data to
alberta.ca each week and a summary will
be shared via my twitter account
i will also provide any other relevant
updates in a weekly media availability
as i said last week and as the minister
has spoken to today
change is difficult especially when
there is no single correct answer to the
difficulties we face
this reporting change may be challenging
for some of us who have grown accustomed
to seeing numbers daily
i know for many this has been a way to
help make sense of a seemingly surreal
situation
fortunately we are in a different place
now
not only do we have a better
understanding of the virus but we also
have highly effective vaccines and
antiviral treatments
and reducing the frequency of reporting
is what makes the most sense in our
current situation
as always i remain committed to keeping
albertans informed and will recommend
modifications if needed in the coming
weeks or months
before concluding i want to advise
albertans of the new guidance we've put
online for at home rapid test sample
collection
we've heard questions from albertans
about the evidence on the omicron
variant that indicates that taking a
sample by swabbing both the mouth and
nose is more effective at detecting
covid19 infection when using a rapid
antigen test
while sampling the nose is still more
effective than the mouth if taking a
sample from only one site
it has been shown that sampling both the
mouth and the nose before processing the
test
can improve the ability to detect the
virus
for those who want to improve the
sensitivity of at home testing we are
providing information about this option
on our website
the overall process remains similar but
there are a few additional steps when
collecting both oral and nasal samples
a video outlining the process for
swabbing the mouth and nose is available
on the rapid testing section of our
website at alberta.ca
i want to repeat that if only one site
is sampled it should be the nose
studies have shown that sampling the
mouth alone is not as sensitive as only
sampling the nose
also as a reminder if you are
symptomatic and test negative you are
still legally required to isolate until
all symptoms are gone
the covid19 assessment tool at ahs.ca
covid screen
is available to help determine what type
of care is needed based on your symptoms
and with advice on how to best manage
mild symptoms at home
finally i want to take a moment to
encourage albertans to continue to be
coveted conscious and take the necessary
precautions that we need to feel
comfortable and that are appropriate to
our level of risk
tomorrow is st patrick's day and i know
many will enjoy gathering with friends
or colleagues at a pub or party
and this month students teachers and
families may take advantage of spring
break with many families planning trips
out of town
whatever the occasion or cause for
celebration i ask that we think about
what we and others around us need to
balance the risks of covid with the
benefits of enjoying more of the
activities we love
the precautions we've grown accustomed
to over the past two years still work
and they are still available
planning outdoor gatherings as the
weather improves is still an option
masking remains a reasonable public
health precaution especially for those
with risk factors it also remains
mandatory in continuing care and health
care settings and public transit to
protect those who are most vulnerable to
severe outcomes
and most importantly if we're not
feeling well we still need to stay home
by doing so we will help prevent the
spread of covid19 and other infectious
diseases
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr henshawn minister i don't see
any reporters here in the room to ask
questions so i think we have a couple on
the line we'll go to the phone please
thank you quinn older global news
hi dr hinshaw i'm wondering if you can
comment on ba2
what kind of presence does the variant
have in alberta and are we monitoring it
we are monitoring ba2 separate from ba1
and over the past a couple of months
we've seen that the proportion of our
cases that our ba2 is slowly increasing
we are still at less than half of our
new detected cases that are ba2 so ba1
is still our dominant strain in alberta
and it's important to remember that what
we've seen in other countries is that
while ba2
seems to transmit more effectively it
does not seem to be a higher risk for
severe outcomes
however as we are watching the
experience of other countries and
watching our own data it's another
important reminder that covet is not
over and we do need to continue to be
mindful about precautions as we go about
our daily lives
thanks her quinn follow up
yes do you think that this is going to
have an impact on hospitalizations and
are we prepared if this potentially
turns into a sixth wave
what we've seen in other countries where
ba2 became dominant early on is that
the
combination of ba1 and then ba2
did cause an increase in cases um with
uh increase in hospitalizations it's
difficult to to tease that apart so for
example in denmark
we saw that
ba1 and ba2
kind of combined in a single wave with a
very high peak however it was manageable
from what's being reported in in the
media that's available
was manageable within the health care
system we are seeing that for example in
the uk there is a little bit of a rise
in cases a bit of a rise in
hospitalizations
but it's really unclear the magnitude of
that increase what i think we should
expect
is to have fluctuations in transmission
over the coming months
we should expect to see covid remaining
with us for the next several months
at i would suggest relatively similar
levels of transmission
which will continue to have people some
people ending up in hospital
i don't anticipate given our current
levels of vaccine coverage
and the relatively recent experience
with ba1 i don't anticipate that we
would see the same
magnitude of impact however will
continue to monitor and of course
respond to any changing data uh if that
does not prove to be true
thanks dr h we'll go to the next caller
please
carly robinson city news
hi there thanks for taking my question
uh i guess i'm just wondering what type
of mechanism will be in place
to
to warn the public or let the public
know when there is a potential next wave
or a next variant uh with with less
reporting is there a commitment to doing
these updates again if we go back to
where we were in in one of the previous
ways
i can start with that question so so the
short answer is is yes um we will make
uh we'll
first of all we need to do an assessment
of of what the next wave might be it may
very well be be a two maybe something
maybe something else
but we will take the necessary steps to
you know as we have get a better
understanding of what the potential
impact is on on our uh
our you know hospitalize our hospitals
and what measures we may or may not need
to take
we will continue to update the update
albertans uh we're you know
at this point in time we're going to be
we you know previously we had you know
multiple updates you know five days a
week what i would say is that
appropriate we drop down to two uh
throughout the omicron wave now we're
down to one uh we're going to continue
this for for a number of weeks and we'll
continue to watch hospitalizations if if
numbers continuing going down and we no
longer need weekly updates uh and media
availabilities we'll we'll still you
know we we may change that down the road
but if we if it's still out there and we
need to actually ramp up the uh ramp up
our communications we'll do so uh but
it's going to be dependent upon what
comes at us next and and what the impact
is going to be on our on our health care
system dr hinshaw anything further
i think the one additional comment i
would make is that
one of the things that we're looking at
is the fact that as we go forward
covert 19 will be one of likely several
respiratory viruses that we need to be
tracking and monitoring so one of the
things that we're looking at is an
ability to regularly report on
respiratory viruses and the picture of
what that looks like in the province
because
again it's the collective impact of all
of the circulating viruses that will be
important for our public health system
and our acute care system so that is
something historically we have always
during influenza season reported at
least weekly on our influenza updates
and so
at a minimum that kind of reporting so
public is the public is aware of what is
circulating is what we're looking at and
then as the minister mentioned adjusting
that if needed depending on
what the situation is at any given
moment in time
thanks dr hitch follow-up carly
hi yes uh it's a bit unrelated but still
on the topic of public health a new
research out of the university of
alberta suggests that the cost of excess
sugar in canadian diets costs the health
care system anywhere between 2.5 billion
and 5 billion each year
i'm wondering what the does the minister
as well as dr kingsha's thoughts are on
on mitigation of this and is a sugar tax
that's maybe used to lower the cost of
more nutritious food
something on your radar
well thanks thanks for the question i
haven't seen the uh the research coming
out of that yet so i'll be interested in
actually taking a look at it and then
see what
and work with officials to see uh what
may be a uh an appropriate response to
that
i don't know anything you've had to add
dr incha no
nothing to add all right thanks very
much minister and dr henshaw uh we'll
wrap there for today
if you need to follow up with us
separately you can do that as always and
we'll see you back here next wednesday
for our first weekly update thanks
everyone thank you